news daily from science mission increase
tetrahydrobiopterin that is bh4 levels
have been associated with pain and
injury scientist in the journal neuron
show that after each nerve injury bh4
levels increased in neurons and
macrophages they have developed a
compound that can bind to bh for
synthesizing enzyme spr and reduce the
formation of bh for without any side
effects reduced bh4 could be monitored
by the CP apter in levels which gets
accumulated depending on the amount of
bh for thereby providing a tool to
control the pain instead of using
narcotics to control pain next
alpha-synuclein aggregates characterized
parkinson's disease and was long
believed to be a natively unfolded
monomer but recent work suggests it can
also occur in alpha helix rich tetra
Mars authors show in the journal Nature
communications that freshly biopsied
normal human brain as well as cultured
neurons and mouse brain contain abundant
tetra mas than monomers also PD causing
a 53 t and e 46 k mutations decreased
data Mars in both animal models and
patient neurons and addition of one to
two extra e 46 k mutations increased
mono Marek forms and in these
neurotoxicity and inclusion bodies
indicating unfolded monomers initiate
pathogenesis for more news visitors at
www science mission calm or science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching